[Música]
son las ocho y treinta de la noche en
Bogotá quito y Lima continuamos en
directo América edición nocturna
seguimos comentando les los principales
hechos del día Les agradecemos su
sintonía vamos con los titulares de esta
jornada
Rusia acusó a Ucrania de realizar el
ataque más profundo contra su territorio
al golpear dos aeródromos asientos de
kilómetros del frente con presuntos
drones ucranianos de fabricación
soviética esto luego produjo que horas
después llegar a una Nueva Ola de
bombardeo sobre territorio ucraniano que
una vez más afectaron la infraestructura
eléctrica del país
entró en vigor el tope al petróleo ruso
acordado por la Unión Europea el g7 y
Australia una medida polémica Pues de
acuerdo con expertos 60 dólares por
barril es un precio muy alto debido a
los costos mucho menores que implica la
producción para Rusia pese a ello el
presidente Vladimir Putin rechazó
cualquier tope
ascendido a 34 el número de víctimas
mortales tras un deslizamiento de tierra
en el occidente de Colombia debido a las
fuertes y continuas lluvias que golpean
al país el gobierno de Gustavo Petro
declaró la alerta Roja en todo el
territorio nacional pues se espera que
las precipitaciones se mantengan al
menos hasta febrero
[Aplausos]
[Música]
damos inicio en Ucrania donde las
autoridades de esa nación denunciaron
una nueva ronda masiva de bombardeos la
octava en ocho semanas los ataques
tuvieron como objetivo una veintena de
infraestructuras civiles y militares en
varias regiones del país generando
nuevos apagones en esas zonas horas
antes Rusia acusó a Ucrania de perpetrar
dos ataques con drones en las dos bases
aéreas de
riazán y saratov que dejaron Al menos
tres muertos Alba Santana tiene los
detalles
asientos de kilómetros de la línea del
frente en Rusia hasta allí consiguieron
llegar dos drones ucranianos que
estallaron en las bases aéreas de raidán
y saratov y que aunque fueron
interceptados se cobraron la vida de al
menos tres soldados
debido a la caída de las explosiones de
los restos de drones en los aeródromos
rusos el revestimiento de la carrocería
de dos aviones resultó dañado y tres
militares rusos técnicos que se
encontraban fueron heridos de muerte
daños que desde el otro bando el de las
fuerzas ucranianas a pesar de no
confirmar su autoría celebraron
Rusia Qué pasó una victoria fugaz y
opacada por la octava Ronda de
bombardeos de Rusia contra Ucrania en
ocho semanas en especial sobre Odessa y
zapodilla que volvieron a dejar al
suroeste del país sin electricidad en
medio de la oscuridad con temperaturas
por debajo de los 0 grados centígrados
todo a pesar de que El Ejecutivo
ucraniano asegura que su defensa aérea
derribó al menos 60 de los 70 misiles
lanzados
una prueba de que el terror puede ser
Derrotado Pero por desgracia todavía no
hay seguridad completa en nuestros
cielos por desgracia hubo víctimas
tenemos cuatro personas muertas debido a
estos ataques
ataques que hicieron sonar las sirenas
en kieva donde muchos ciudadanos se
refugiaron de un posible ataque en
estaciones de metro
Espero que no haya destrucciones masivas
esperaron hasta que la temperatura
llegara a los cinco menos seis grados
centígrados hasta que hizo frío
todo mientras el presidente Vladimir
Putin visitaba El puente del estrecho de
kerch conduciendo un Mercedes Benz el
puente más grande de Europa que
conectaba la Península de crimea
anexionada por Rusia en 2014 Consuelo
ruso pero que el 8 de octubre sufrió un
atentado que los rusos achacan a las
fuerzas militares ucranianas este lunes
entraron en vigor dos limitaciones con
las que la Unión Europea Busca reducir
las ganancias económicas de Rusia por el
petróleo por un lado el bloque prohibió
todas las importaciones de crudo ruso
por vía marítima y también la Unión
Europea el g7 y Australia comenzaron a
aplicar el límite de precio al barril de
petróleo de Rusia para no comprarlo por
encima de 60 dólares
Moscú ha dicho que no acatará la medida
Incluso si tiene que cortar su
producción y algunos abogan por un
límite mucho más estricto como lo pide
el presidente ucraniano
les contamos más en el informe
a partir de este lunes será más difícil
para los rusos vender su petróleo en
Europa
Moscú no podrá vender su crudo
transportado por mar hacia el viejo
continente pues entra en vigor el
embargo acordado por el bloque de los 27
se estima que el castigo afectaría el
90% de las importaciones europeas unos
730 millones de barriles anuales y que a
partir del 5 de febrero También atacará
las importaciones de derivados una
medida que no llega sola pues este lunes
también comienza a regir otro golpe para
la economía rusa el tope de precio
pactado en 60 dólares por barril para el
crudo de Moscú Ese fue el techo fijado
por la Unión Europea el g7 y Australia
el g7 y todos los estados miembros de la
Unión Europea han tomado una decisión
que afectará aún más los ingresos de
Rusia y reducirá su capacidad para hacer
la guerra en Ucrania sin embargo las
medidas buscan que el petróleo que se
produce en Rusia pueda seguir fluyendo
minimizando el choque para el resto del
mundo
a partir de mediados de enero el nivel
se revisará cada dos meses buscando
dejar al crudo ruso 5% por debajo del
precio promedio de Mercado y permite el
envío de petróleo ruso utilizando buques
cisterna del g7 y de la Unión Europea
solo si este es comprado al precio
máximo establecido o por debajo del
mismo una disposición que afectaría la
venta del crudo ruso debido a que las
principales empresas de transporte y
seguros del mundo tienen su sede en los
países del g7 y la Unión Europea Rusia
fue categórica negándose a aceptar el
techo y dijo estar incluso dispuesta a
reducir su producción por su parte la
Organización de Países exportadores de
petróleo y sus aliados determinaron el
domingo que mantendrán la producción de
petróleo reducida en dos millones de
barriles diarios hasta finales de 2023
una decisión que aunque señalaron
responde exclusivamente a
consideraciones de Mercado ya fue
duramente criticada por Estados Unidos
cambiamos de tema y Vamos hasta Colombia
porque un deslizamiento de tierra en una
del departamento de risaralda en el
occidente del país deja un saldo de al
menos 34 personas muertas según
informaron las autoridades las labores
de búsqueda ya terminaron además
declararon la alerta máxima por la
fuerte temporada de lluvias que
experimenta el país Andrés triviño nos
cuenta más
la imparable temporada de lluvias en
Colombia sigue cobrando vidas un
deslizamiento de tierra en el
departamento colombiano de risaralda
mató a decenas de personas después que
el autobús en el que se desplazaban
quedara sepultado el bus se encontraba
sepultado a unos dos metros bajo tierra
Así mismo llevaba un total de 37
personas incluido el conductor y su
ayudante de las cuales fallecieron 34
entre los cuales se encuentran ocho
menores al parecer otros vehículos
particulares también quedaron bajo
tierra El deslizamiento se produjo el
domingo en una vía que comunica al
centro con el occidente del país según
las autoridades el terreno se encontraba
fuertemente afectado luego de varios
días de lluvias lo cual complicó las
labores de rescate que ya terminaron
debido a que se trata de una zona
montañosa y un terreno inestable desde
agosto del 2020 Colombia ha sufrido los
estragos del fenómeno de la niña dejando
tras su paso más del 60% de los
municipios afectados los pronósticos
estiman que el fen se mantendrá hasta
por lo menos febrero del 2023
queremos declarar nuestra alerta máxima
en todo el territorio por esta ola
invernal que ha traído tanto daño
material y también en vidas como la que
acaba de ocurrir la unidad nacional para
la gestión del riesgo de desastres instó
a los habitantes de la zona abandonar
sus hogares ya que se podrían presentar
nuevos deslizamientos mientras las
lluvias siguen afectando todo el país
vamos ahora Argentina donde el
presidente Alberto Fernández anunció que
pedirá la justicia una investigación
contra un grupo de empresarios jueces
Fiscales y exfuncionarios por
presuntamente hacer parte de una trama
de corrupción el mandatario argentino
hizo referencia a un supuesto viaje en
un avión privado a la localidad del Lago
escondido en la Patagonia a la mansión
de Joe Louis un acaudalado Hombre de
negocios británico los detalles con
nuestro corresponsal en Buenos Aires
natalio cosoy
quienes aparecen en la filtraciones
hablan de espionaje ilegal de una
operación en su contra del otro lado lo
señalan especialmente a los funcionarios
del poder judicial de haber desarrollado
una actividad incompatible con sus
funciones esa reunión cerca de Bariloche
en lado escondido una en una propiedad
del Magnate estadounidense Joe Luis un
hombre cercano al ex presidente Mauricio
macri la realidad es que no está claro
En qué consistió ese encuentro y los
protagonistas tampoco han salido a
explicar exactamente de qué se trató Y
eso Abre a suspicacias bueno el
presidente Alberto Fernández en su
declaración pública en Cadena Nacional
habló de eso habló de que le solicitó al
ministro de Justicia que avanzara con
una acusación con una denuncia a los
protagonistas de este encuentro y de la
filtraciones hay que ver hacia qué lado
va Lo cierto es que hay que recordar que
en Argentina el poder judicial tiene muy
mala imagen y hay algo más Esto se está
dando en el contexto en el que este
martes se conocerá la sentencia
potencial puede ser absolutoria o
condenatoria de la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández de kirchner en la
causa vialidad en la que los acusados
están investigados por asociación
ilícita y defraudación al estado y esta
noticia no hace más que enrarecer aún
más el clima en este momento en
Argentina
vamos ahora a Turquía porque Durante los
últimos años en este país y
particularmente en la ciudad de Estambul
se han convertido en el lugar de
residencia principal de un gran número
de disidentes y opositores de oriente
próximo que marchan a la ciudad del
bósforo en busca de un lugar seguro
donde no serán perseguidos conocemos más
detalles y algunas de las historias de
estos exiliados en el siguiente
reportaje
la vida de vilar hace nueve años dio un
vuelco su padre Fue encarcelado en un
centro de retención en China y ante el
miedo de ir también a prisión por formar
parte de La minoría vigor huyó a Turquía
donde inició una nueva vida
estábamos tristes cuando salimos de
china porque habíamos abandonado nuestra
casa pero al llegar a Estambul vimos que
podíamos construir aquí una nueva vida
que aquí podíamos estar seguros nadie
nos obliga a nada nadie nos hace nada
Durante los últimos años Estambul se ha
convertido en Un refugio para miles de
exiliados y perseguidos de países de
Asia central y Oriente próximo
mikel una bailarina iraní ha escogido al
país San Antonio como otros exiliados
por ser más libre que el resto de sus
vecinos en Irán su oficio está prohibido
como mínimo en Turquía puedo bailar
claro no es como en Europa como los
Estados Unidos como Canadá lo sé pero en
Turquía como mínimo puedo bailar es lo
que más quiero en este mundo y si no
pudiese bailar no estaría aquí si no
pudiese Me sentiría como enferma
las libertades en Turquía sin embargo
tienen un límite hay más nuevos
propietario de alshark televisión
egipcia en el exilio que transmite sin
censura desde 2015 contra el gobierno
egipcio de del fatah recibió advertencia
de oficiales turcos de vigilar su
mensaje tras el acercamiento de Turquía
con el militar egipcio no queremos que
nos afecte la mejora de relaciones entre
los gobiernos de Turquía y Egipto pero
en caso de que pueda pasar Egipto debe
saber que nos moveríamos a otro país
donde no haya límites con más libertades
y creo que saben que esto no les
ayudaría
su lucha sin embargo sigue para nur y
sus 150 trabajadores Estambul se ha
convertido en su hogar a pesar de los
retos y las presiones
en Francia Los profesionales de la salud
piden al gobierno que vuelva a ser
obligatorias las mascarillas ya que las
infecciones por covid-19 y las
hospitalizaciones están en aumento en
todo el país mientras que algunos acogen
con satisfacción la noticia de que los
tapabocas podrían volver a ser
obligatorios generando descontento entre
quienes están hartos de la pandemia
Francia se prepara para afrontar su
novena oleada de Kobe 19 y para los
ciudadanos podría ser el momento de
regresar a los viejos hábitos ya que
muchos en el país están pidiendo que
vuelva a ser obligatorio el uso de las
mascarillas en el transporte público
creo que es esencial que vuelva la
mascarilla mucha gente tose y nadie sabe
respetar las normas de distanciamiento
social yo tengo mi mascarilla pero
mientras no sea obligatoria no me la
pondré porque me molestó el gobierno
francés dice estar listo para tomar
medidas si la novena ola se sale de
control antes de las vacaciones
sí un cochinillo monté si las
infecciones siguen aumentando no dudaré
en hacer obligatorio las mascarillas
desde hace un mes los casos de Kobe 19
han vuelto a aumentar en Francia la
semana pasada hubo una media de
50,604 casos diarios es decir el doble
de infecciones que a principios de
noviembre y el tema de las vacunas
vuelve a estar en el centro del debate
no estoy vacunado no me he puesto la
primera ni la segunda dosis nos fuimos
de vacaciones Así que tuvimos que
asegurarnos de tener todas nuestras
dosis las autoridades siguen haciendo
campaña para que todos se vacunen ya que
solo el 21% de los mayores de 80 años y
más ha recibido todas las dosis Así
finalizamos esta edición de directo a
América aquí en France 24 a ustedes Les
agradecemos su sintonía y los invitamos
a que continúen con nosotros que ya
llega a malbecnotman con toda la
actualidad del continente africano en
África 7 días feliz noche para todos
[Música]